Яка краса була, як було багато гончарів!
Така була краса! Ми палимо горшки,
по всіх вулицях, всюди трудяться і співають
Співають люди, а ми випалюємо.
А тепер палиш — тільки собаки гавкають.
Де ж це ділося?
Де всі ці співи? Де радість ділася?
Насамперед, я ніколи не осмислюю того, що я роблю.
Я роблю, не знаю чому.
І тоді я починаю відчувати,
що мене просто хтось веде.
Я просто довіряю тому, хто мене веде.
Я думаю, що це не тільки бабуся, дідусь.
Весь мій гончарський рід.
Це якась вища сила,
яка розуміє, що це потрібно.
Бо гончарство — це одне із ремесел,
яке дозволяє людині знаходити самого себе
і додає віри в свої сили, що людина
може сама щось зробити.
Навіть нічого не маючи зробити і зробивши — заробити.
Якби не музей, я думаю, що,
можливо, гончарства вже тут би не було.
Як воно зникає в багатьох інших осередках гончарства.
Корені захоплення нашого роду гончарством
сягають принаймні другої половини XVIII століття.
Коли в літературі вже зафіксовані гончарі Пошивайли,
які в Опішному займалися гончарством.
І гончарство входило в мене не лише через свою родину,
а й через загалом гончарне містечко Опішне,
де кожен третій-четвертий мешканець
був пов'язаний з гончарством
Які в нас в Опішні майстри!
Гончарі, кравці, шевці були.
Плотники.
Усі! Такі люди були терплячі!
За свою глину раді голодні робить і вмерти там,
бо такі дружні були.
Боже, які люди були!
Куряк Іван, Сердюченко.
Це Володька, Яценки два.
Вже виряжали їх у армію.
То я понесла їм усім рублі.
Бо мати, кажу, щоби з фронту мені усі поприносили.
Білик один прийшов, а то всі пропали.
Бабуся ще на початку 1970-х років
створила домашній музей гончарства.
Я теж, мабуть, звідти перейняв
свій перший досвід створення музею,
розбудови, і вже потім, у своїй професійній діяльності,
продовжив те, що започаткувала бабуся.
І, як вона нічого, крім гончарства,
особливо не знала, так само і я.
До сьогодні, крім музею і гончарства, не мислю свого життя.
Такі були гончарі, що вже їх як не пом'янути
оце зараз і музей зробити, виставити фотографії.
Я хочу навіть щоб не вмерти,
поки музей буде, подивлюсь.
Так хочеться подивитися.
Взагалі, якби в Україні не було криз,
то ми би ніколи не розбудували такого музею.
Коли в Україні настав такий час,
що ми не мали коштів на придбання, скажімо, експонатів,
ми почали проводити симпозіуми кераміки.
Таким чином ми створили
грандіозний парк монументальної скульптури,
який є перлиною нашого музею.
І до сьогодні, а музею вже виповнилося
цього року 30 років, ми робимо те, що ми хочемо.
Як ми це відчуваємо, як ми розуміємо.
І по суті жоден державний орган,
якому ми підпорядковувались,
в цей процес не втручався.
Перші кроки були найважчі, бо потрібно було переконати
чиновників в потребі створення цього музею.
Я починав сам, потім приєдналося
ще три співробітники. І так потрохи.
До сьогодні, коли за штатним розписом
у нас 108 працівників музею
Я дуже радію з того, що по суті розбудовниками
нашого музею є всі мешканці України,
які ідуть у музей і платять за вхідний квиток.
Держава дає кошти тільки на заробітні
плати працівників, на комунальні послуги.
Все інше ми робимо самі, і нічого ні в кого не просимо.
І ще втішає те, що
я якось не надавав значення ніколи цьому,
але читаю відгуки про те, що ми в музеї
відчули себе українцями.
Я думаю, що це по суті і є місією
будь-якого музею в Україні.
Не просто, як скарбниці якихось старожитностей,
а як живий організм, який примушує
людину осмислити себе
і себе в українському світі.